you're having so much success and
whenever uh you're out there killing it
i'm happy for you because you're a good
person and i root for you
but i want to go back
to talk about st louis because you come
from st louis and i swear to god that's
got to be key it's got to be key to your
origin story don't you think yeah and i
live there now too oh you moved i moved
back there i moved back during so
during covid it kind of i was doing your
show when everything kind of shut down
right my parents were
i'm constantly exposing you to things
and i was out here doing your show and
my parents were with me because they're
huge fans and i whenever
i can i i like to bring them along and
um and the world was shutting down and
then i just went back to st louis with
them because i figured
my apartment was in new york but these
[ __ ] straws
you just keep bumping into that straw
don't you
um
let me just describe what's happening
yes we're providing these metallic
straws because we're trying to save the
oceans uh which is i think noble of us
but those straws are very aggressive
they stick out quite a ways and every
time you gesture with your hand you go
slamming into it
this will end up in the ocean you're
getting vodka all over me
so so anyway back to saint louis because
that's where my parents live and the
world was shutting down and i was kind
of scared and i just stayed there and i
lived with my parents for 10 months i i
don't unders listen
i you have a really good point in my
career too you are things are going good
things are going very well for you i
have to tell you i love my parents yeah
uh but if i move back in with them
i would take my own life within three
days
and i mean that with so much love and
caring but i would i would i was
thinking about doing that very thing
within three months i think was the time
frame for me where it was got real dark
and it's just that we're not meant to go
back at that point
and you are much younger than me
obviously but i don't see how you could
handle that i was like 35 or 36 when
this was all going down and and things
were going well like you don't move back
in with your parents unless
you're broke or asian you know as an
adult so it's
it's acceptable
i'm sorry i'm just checking my notes to
see if we're in trouble here
i don't think i don't think we are
armenian
yeah i think it's sweet but or the
oldest child in a catholic family yes
yeah okay a computer coder
[Laughter]
anyone who's really into dungeons and
dragons
but i was doing it because i was i was
scared
of being alone i saw
comedy clubs are going to shut down
right the places i hang out to not feel
alone and and and so i just was like i
need mommy and daddy i mean it really
was being scary i slept on my parents
floor until i was like eighth grade like
i was a scared child so i think i just
reverted back to being horrified wanting
to be with mom and dad thinking it was
gonna be a couple weeks and then it
ended up being ten months and i only
moved out
because it just got sad to to tell
people that i was living with my parents
it got too embarrassing but i was having
a good time i mean they're usually when
you live with your parents as an adult
or you visit home they're usually sick
you're seeing this like
sad side of things but my parents are
still really vital and fun and so i was
having a great time but i had to move
out and i was too scared to go back to
new york or la i was scared to go back
to where i would feel constant pressure
to be out every night doing stand-up
comedy
saying yes to every podcast i was just i
couldn't stop saying yes to things and
so i kind of stayed in st louis to stay
away from
my drug which is work